for reaction let's bring in republican
senator marcia blackburn from tennessee
who serves on the senate armed services
committee commerce and judiciary
committees
uh senator thanks for joining us i just
want to get your your thoughts on those
speeches again
a serious focus on where america has
come from
those who help build america into the
greatest country in the world and a
positive look
to the future for all americans
oh charles i thought the speech was
absolutely one of the best that he has
given
and how appropriate that he reminded the
american people
that we are unique and that you can bet
on hope or you can bet on fear but
in this country you have the ability
to do whatever you want to do to dream
those big dreams
and make them come true and you and i
have talked in times past about how
we have each put a focus on encouraging
young people
from underserved areas and wouldn't it
be fabulous to have this
national garden where people could go
and be inspired and say i want to do
something that is going to be
significant for my country
yeah it's interesting because the the
white house just announcing that they do
have pants for a national garden
uh that could possibly open july 4th
2026.
the media taking shots saying it was an
arbitrary or random list of americans
i'm not sure
what's so random about john adams susan
b anthony henry clay daniel boone davy
crockett franklin
frederick douglass amelia earhart uh
martin luther king jr abraham lincoln
douglas macarthur betsy ross harriet
beecher snow ronald reagan jackie
robinson
booker t washington harriet tubman
george washington
the wright brothers and now the list
goes on that sounds like a pretty good
list a pretty good foundation of what's
shaped and formed
who we are today i think it is a great
foundation because you know what those
of us that
studied history and appreciate history
can tick through that list
and tell you something of significance
that
each of those individuals did or said
that inspired us in some way
so as they are putting this list
together i think it is really wonderful
and how appropriate
you're talking about frederick douglass
and susan b anthony
and this is the year we're celebrating
the 19th amendment and women getting the
right to vote
that is going to be august 18th 2020 the
centennial celebration
and and the speech itself particularly
one at mount rushmore
when the president said that the
founding fathers launched a revolution
in pursuit of justice equality liberty
and prosperity
it kind of reminded me of hamilton right
the biggest media event over the weekend
how many people have watched hamilton
and the same folks that said that this
is an amazing play
with an inspiring message found racism
division
and these kind of words from president
trump so i just can't understand
why at some point even the media should
let their guards down and
let americans celebrate where we've come
and how we've gotten here so fast
that is so true and we want to make
certain and the president spoke to this
we do not need to erase our nation's
history
it is all there the good the bad the
ugly the inspirational
the achievement the overcoming
the the the pride that people should
take
in the fact that they have been able to
achieve
and do and be there are millions of
people
from all across the globe that seek to
come to the united states
every single year because they are
escaping
oppression and because they want to be
able to achieve their dreams and they've
read about
our land as a land of hope and
opportunity and freedom
so they choose to come here i think the
garden is a great idea
the president's speech was the right
tone
talking about this country and this
country's achievements and the
achievements
of our people which is what makes
it which makes our country great you
know people felt like
president trump believed in them in
2016.
indeed he did right and he has proven
that
and so now to say here is where we can
go with our children and grandchildren
and say this is someone who made a
difference in our lives
senator i want to switch gears here a
little bit the covet 19 cases have been
on the rise throughout the nation
and i think the most recent numbers from
tennessee show
continuing spike in this case and so you
know the idea is what do we do
uh we do see where master now being man
being mandatory
uh in many states that they weren't
before did we open too quickly or was it
just sort of a situation where people
uh just were so have been so pent up so
cooped up
that they overindulged here and and how
long do you think it will get before
we're sort of back on track
with reopening the nation
i think getting back on track very
quickly and here is the reason why
you were seeing people who got out there
their kids got out there they went to
protests
they went into these groups and now what
do you have you have spikes whether it
was protest or bars or
or whatever so i've talked to a lot of
moms who are saying
i've told my kids and my young adults
you have to wear a mask you have to wash
your hands
and they know they want to get out and
about and charles here's the thing we
cannot afford another lockdown in this
economy 4.8 million jobs the jobs report
the numbers were good people want to go
to work
they need to do it safely they need to
wear their mask they need to wear gloves
use a face shield if they need to they
need to
wash their hands and they need to make
certain that their children are and even
if they're adults
make certain that their children are
doing these same things their
grandchildren are doing it
because kids have got to get back to
school and
kids have got to get back to colleges if
you are not putting kids back in
colleges you don't have
young teachers coming along to help
teach children you don't have young
medical students
getting through medical school and then
getting out to do those residencies and
practice
medicine we have to get ourselves back
on track
and here's another thing charles we do
not want to hand the keys
of this economy that is roaring back to
life
we don't want to hand those keys to the
marxists and the socialists
we've got less than a minute to go and i
know you're passionate about these two
topics i don't know we can give
answers on both but of course you share
president trump's worries about melon
voting and the fraud associated with
that but something else that you've been
working on
with this ncaa the nil name images and
likeness
you have pushed hard for this and it
looks like these student athletes
are going to start having some control
over their own financial futures
because of who they are
when it comes to nil yes i think that
we have given the ncaa a deadline if
they can't get their act together we
will get it together for them but
they're going to resolve
this issue and we're going to have a
standard so that these parents
and these young athletes know what to
expect likewise
i know you're talking to gordon in a few
minutes i've been pretty hard on the nba
about their relationship with communist
china
and when it comes to dealing with that
they need to be held to account
for this and let me flip to the mail in
voting
i've served on an election commission as
a citizen
in service in my county i think that we
trust our local election commissions
to run those elections fair and square
that is where the accountability needs
to be
i'm very leery of mail in voting
you're not the only one senator marcia
blackburn thank you very much